these are the nominees for the best
supporting actress
brad pitt brought his signature swagger
to the 2021
oscars and had the best supporting
actress nominees
totally blushing mr bread pit
finally nice to meet you on sunday the
oscar winner took the stage to present
the award for best supporting actress
i mean i feel pretty privileged looking
as dapper as ever in a classic black
tuxedo
and ponytail and he had a few of the
ladies
swooning as he talked about their early
inspiration
for maria bacaliva it was all about
marilyn monroe
she'd write out maryland's quote i'm
going to be a great movie star someday
maria welcome
glenn close was smiling ear to ear and
for the great glenn close
she was entranced by classic disney
movies like snow white
and old yeller and apparently paid off
she ended up being cast as cruella
deville
and he brought all the charm introducing
amanda syphred
who said she was inspired by leonardo
dicaprio's flick romeo and juliet
amanda me too
the award ultimately went to xi jong
yoon for her role in menari
and needless to say she was totally star
struck by the hunky actor
mr britt pitt finally
nice to meet you and while brad was an
executive producer on minari
that moment right there marked their
first in-person meeting
where were you while we were filming in
tulsa
it's very honoured to meet you the
actress also gave fellow nominee glenn
close
a special shout out i don't believe in
competition
how can i win glenn close up we know
about glenn close
i've been watching her so many
performances
before praising the other women in her
category
so this is just all the nominees five
nominees so we are the winner for the
different movie different
we play the different world so we cannot
compete each other
and when she wrapped up her speech brad
helped her make her way backstage
what a gentleman yeah and sha jung she
thinks so too
use movie star for me so
i couldn't believe he was leading
to me or he announced my name backstage
the oscar winner said she was
super impressed with how well he
pronounced her name
i saw him on the stage and then
he called my name i can tell
he practiced a lot he didn't
mispronounce my name
then at that moment then when i got
there
i just lost what's
what i supposed to say what
should i begin or something so
[Music]
you